شجرة النخيل الأجنبية المتواضعة هي
مرادفة للشرق الأوسط مثل الزيت
والرمل ولكنها لذيذة مثل التمر،
نحن لسنا هنا من أجل الأشياء الحلوة، نحن
هنا من أجل هذا
بشكلها البيضاوي وحجم نواة
تمر اللوز.  بقايا
المنتجات الثانوية أثناء المعالجة وعلى مدى
السنوات القليلة الماضية، كانت هذه الأكوام من التمر هي
محور
التجارب العلمية في جامعة أبو ظبي.
لقد لاحظت أن هناك الكثير من النفايات
الناتجة عن الحفر الميتة، لذلك ركزت
اهتماماتي البحثية على عزل
المركبات  من النوى الميتة، يطحنون نواة
التمر إلى مسحوق ناعم،
ويقول آرون وفريقها إنهم وجدوا نوى التمر غنية بالبروتين
والكربوهيدرات والمعادن والألياف،
واكتشفوا أيضًا أن لها
خصائص مضادة للميكروبات، مما يعني أنه
يمكن استخدامها لمنع نمو
البكتيريا والفطريات والفيروسات.
لمعرفة ما إذا كان يمكن استخدام الحفر الميتة
في تربية الأحياء المائية،
تعتبر تربية الأسماك المائية
صناعة عالمية ضخمة،
وانتقلت إلى البحث فيما إذا كان
يمكن استخدام المستخلصات من الحفر الميتة
كإضافات غذائية محتملة في
علف الأسماك لزيادة تعزيز
نمو الأسماك وهو أمر ذو أهمية تجارية.
لمزارعي الأسماك وأيضًا
للنظر فيما إذا كان بإمكاننا استخدامها للوقاية
من الأمراض، فقد
أضافوا نواة التمر إلى
علف الأسماك ويقولون إنه يمكن استخدامها لتعزيز
نمو الأسماك ويعتقدون أيضًا
أن نواة التمر يمكن أن توفرها
مضاد حيوي طبيعي في مكافحة
الأمراض في الأسماك، وجدنا نشاطًا جيدًا جدًا
مضادًا للميكروبات ضد
مسببات الأمراض الشائعة في الأسماك خلال الأشهر القليلة المقبلة،
وسوف يطبقون نتائجهم في
التجارب المعملية على الأسماك الفعلية ربما
في العام أو العامين المقبلين بمجرد أن نتمكن من ذلك  "لقد
أجرينا تجارب ميدانية، ربما يمكننا
البدء في عمليات استرداد الإنتاج على نطاق واسع،
حيث وجدنا استخدامًا لمخلفات نواة التمر، وهي
مصدر جديد لتغذية الأسماك، ومن
المحتمل أن تؤدي إلى اختراقات في
علاج الأمراض في الأسماك